mosey nation two days ago i was speaking
with some business owners that
approached me about becoming portfolio
companies and acquisition.com and i want
to talk to you about how that
conversation went um and i want to give
you one of the most useful frameworks
that i use in analyzing a business that
you can use today to analyze your own
business and instantly 2-3 exit which is
exactly what i do when i'm looking at
the portfolio companies that we're
considering on investing in
the beautiful thing about this equation
and as you as you develop as an
entrepreneur at least as i have and just
so you if you guys don't know who i am
my name is alex romozy on
acquisition.com our portfolio companies
do about 85 million a year and i have
absolutely nothing to sell you all right
and so the reason i make this channel is
because a lot of people are broke and i
want you to be one of them and mozi
nation is not going to be one of them
everyone needs if you are good at
something you need tools all right this
equation is one of those tools that you
have as an entrepreneur if you have to
rely on your your systems if you have to
rely on finance to get you the reports
to get to make
general directional decisions then
you're going to be weak as an
entrepreneur because you have to be able
to do these calculations in your head
back of napkin all right and so i want
to show you the most valuable equation
that i use in analyzing my own
businesses and potential portfolio
companies and it requires five variables
and i'm going to show you what they are
and then i'm going to show you how i got
the two hardest numbers that most people
don't know how to get within their
business all right so i can even give
you the sixth number which will be a
bonus one number one is going to be
number of new sales per month most
people know this number the next one is
current revenue so that's most people
also know this number the next number is
price most people know this number the
next number is going to be churn most
people do not know this number
the next number is going to be lifetime
value most people do not know this
number the next number is gross profit
all right so i'm going to show you how
in a simple conversation we can figure
out all of these things and extrapolate
where business is going to cap out where
the weak points are and how we can see
what the size of the opportunity all
right so i'm going to give you a
hypothetical example that i just had i
was talking to a business they were
doing a hundred new sales per month all
right so that's number one i said cool
what are you guys doing in revenue right
now they were doing uh 400k
in revenue i said okay this is really
important you will want to pay attention
to this video they had 380 clients all
right their current price was a thousand
dollars per month churn they didn't know
lifetime value they didn't know all
right
so i said okay well the first thing we
have to do is figure out where your
hypothetical max is going to be all
right so if we know the current number
of new sales because they were like well
i i i have to get you these numbers
later i don't have them on me i was like
if you know these numbers we can do them
live together and they're like oh i was
like yeah so let's walk through it okay
a thousand dollars a month is the price
right and i said okay well how many
customers are canceling every week and
they said 13 people per week were
cancelling i was like okay so roughly 50
per month okay
makes sense everyone good here they said
they have 380 active clients what we do
is we take 380 active clients we divide
it by 50. oops sorry 50 uh 50 people
cancelling divided by 380 active clients
i already did the math for you it's 13
churn all right
so
now we take our price all right which is
a thousand dollars per client
per month we divided by that 13 churn
and we get 7 700 bucks all right roughly
so now
i know that seventy seven hundred
dollars
is going to be the ltv per customer all
right
which means that this business is going
to cap out at 770k
per month all right which is about 9
million bucks a year
now they were currently doing about 400k
now the thing is there's a lot of
business and they're growing really
rapidly right it makes sense because
they were because they had this kind of
sales velocity so with this kind of
sales velocity they're going to keep
growing pretty quickly and then it's
going to become an asymptote which looks
like this all right so an asymptote is
you have a hypothetical max and it and
it approaches it but never gets there
all right so the asymptote here will be
770k the thing is is that the growth
rate would slow down because churn is
going to start eating a bigger and
bigger and bigger percentage of the new
business that is coming in we know the
current clients we knew the new sales we
know the current revenue right we know
the hypothetical max
which for me helps me analyze the
potential opportunity of this business
right
we know the churn now which is 13
percent we know the lifetime
value of each customer now which is 7
700 and i asked them what kind of
margins are we running
on this and they were running over 90
gross margins all right and the easy way
to do that is how much does it cost to
to fulfill a customer so for them for
that thousand dollar month customer it
cost them less than a hundred dollars uh
to fulfill on all right so it was very
very very low cost business which means
all you do is you multiply this by 0.9
and then you get
let's see here let's see if i can do my
own math really quickly all right so now
you get
roughly let's say 7 000 okay
so the lifetime gross profit per
customer is seven thousand dollars which
means as long as we're spending less
than seven thousand dollars to acquire
customer we are going to be a profitable
business right for the most part when we
had this little discussion all right
let's go back to our little drawing we
know that they're going to cap right at
70
700 k right whatever i'm saying here
right so if we want to grow this
business we either have to increase this
one or we have to increase this one
that's it you can only grow a business
by getting more customers or making them
worth more period that's all we have to
do and within this particular business
i saw the opportunity here because i saw
13
churn right because check out how this
goes if we can just cut the churn to
let's say three percent
ah
let's do some cool math you want to see
something really quick sure alex i want
to see all right fine i'll show you so
if we change this to just three percent
churn all right
the new ltv becomes 33 000 per customer
now
this business all of a sudden without
changing anything else becomes a three
point three million dollar per month
business
that will become the new hypothetical
hypothetical cap and almost all of that
would be margin ah
much more interesting right what most
people do is they say hey i want to take
this thing and see how we can get it to
uh you know a thousand
right which would be you know awesome
because then that would get us to 7.7
million per month
but which of these do you think is
easier to do 10xing the acquisition or
simply dropping your turn from 13 to 3
percent and there's lots of ways to drop
churn and i had a different video or i
said how i cracked netflix recurring
revenue model there's eight c's to d to
increase your stick or decrease your
churn whatever way you want to say it
that we'd be going through to figure out
how we can cut churn from 13 to 3
percent and fyi for a company to have
enterprise value most private equity
firms want to see 80
yearly retention meaning you keep you
keep 80 of your clients per year so if
you start at a thousand beginning of the
year you have 800 at the end of the year
all right now if anyone wants to venture
a guess at what 13
your monthly churn looks like you're
probably keeping less than 20
of your customers by the end of the year
all right and so for them they don't
think that's an enterprise that's very
valuable because what they're looking at
just in case i'll give you guys a little
nugget here all right there's three main
variables that they're going to be
looking at any kind of any kind of
potential buyer which is what's the
growth number one number two is how
likely stickiness which is like how
likely is the the business gonna be here
and then what's the profit right
so you could pretty much multiply these
things together which is if i have a
super fast growth company all of the
revenue is super sticky and we're very
profitable and this is going to be a
very very very valuable business if i
have a a business that uh is mediumly
growing right it is not sticky and i
have low profit then this is going to be
a low value business and so the
objective for us at acquisition.com is
how do we take one of these guys
right one of these businesses and turn
them into one of these businesses and so
it's really looking at these fundamental
metrics to figure out where the weak
points in the business model exist all
right so right now if you're a business
owner
and you don't know what your
hypothetical max is with your current
model and your current numbers
you are fooling yourself you don't know
where you're going to cap out which
means you don't know where your weak
points are all right and so right now
everyone should be able to do this math
within their own business without any
kind of complex recording without any
kind of you know excel sheets that are
getting sent from finance all you need
to do is you got to know how many new
customers you're getting which is this
guy
how many new sales you're getting how
many current clients you have where your
current revenue is right what your
prices are you should know all that
stuff and as long as you can know how
many people are canceling every month
then you can calculate the rest of this
entire equation for yourself and figure
out how you can de-bottleneck the growth
of your business because i'm a big
believer in the theory of constraints
which is a business will grow
up to its nearest constraint and so all
i try and do is simply remove the
constraints of the business to allow it
to grow right i see businesses organic
beings they want to grow and they're
simply being constrained by something
and our goal is to find what the biggest
constraint is and remove it most people
try and do lots of things i believe that
the smartest people in the world try and
find how to do the fewest things that
get them the most returns and removing
the biggest constraint is the biggest
one of those anywho my friends this is
alex ramose reporting in from
acquisition.com we're doing 85 million a
year in our portfolio revenue and i have
absolutely nothing to sell you mosey
nation keep being awesome if you enjoyed
this and you're new to the channel hit
subscribe if you liked it if you didn't
like it i love you either way keep being
awesome i'll see you guys in the next
vid bye